-Hey, everyone.
Tonight is a very special
Edition of "The Tonight Show.
We're lucky enough to do
our show every night here
in 30 Rockefeller Center
in New York City.
Normally, we're in Studio 6b
just inside these doors,
but tonight we're going
to change things up.
We're going to do something that
we've always wanted to do.
We're taking "The Tonight Show"
underground
to the New York City subway.
Our only guest tonight is one
of the biggest bands
in the world,
BTS are on the show.
They're going to ride
the subway with me.
They've never written before.
We're going to get
something to eat
and then we're going
to Grand Central Terminal.
They are shutting it down
for us
because BTS will put willing
on an epic performance.
Nothing like this
has ever been down before.
It's all happening tonight,
but first,
we have to get to the train.
Let's go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-From the F train below
Rockefeller Center
in the New York subway system.
It's "The Tonight Show Starring
Jimmy Fallon."
-♪ Hey, hey, hey, hey ♪
-Tonight joining Jimmy
and his guest, BTS.
And featuring
the legendary Roots crew.
-♪ Hey, hey, hey, hey ♪
-And now, here's your host,
Jimmy Fallon.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Welcome.
Welcome to "The Tonight Show,"
everybody.
Yes.
Guys, I'm so excited about this.
BTS is my guest tonight.
[ Cheers and applause ]
This is very historic
because this is the first time
New Yorkers
have been excited to see
seven guys get on
a packed subway,
so thank you for that.
Can you hear me in the back?
[ Cheers and applause ]
We are making TV history
as the first in late night
to do a show on the subway.
It's exciting
because if it goes well,
NBC is going to move
the fifth hour
of the "Today" show down here.
So that's good, yeah.
This is incredible.
We really are doing the
monologue on the subway.
We actually wanted
to this last week,
but the train never showed up.
[ Laughter ]
But seriously, tonight
is going to be so much fun.
We're going to spend
one hour together,
or as it's known on
the subway, two stops.
[ Laughter ]
It's great to be down here,
though.
It's cramped, it's loud
and there's no view.
If this were a New York City
apartment,
it'd be 3,000 bucks a month.
You know that?
[ Laughter ]
But I'm excited to do a show
on the subway,
although I'm not really here
by choice.
Unfortunately,
NBC lost their entire budget
on the movie "Cats"
and this is all we can afford.
I would have to say I love
New York City so much.
We are the home of all the best
parades, right?
[ Cheers and applause ]
The St. Patricks Day parade,
the Thanksgiving, Pride,
the list goes,
and actually a long,
long, time ago,
we eve had parades
for our winning sports teams.
It was a magical,
magical moment.
[ Audience boos ]
-Don't you make fun of the Mets.
-You can't throw me off,
it's a moving train.
I'm stuck here.
Another thing I love
about the city
is that it's so modern.
For instance,
instead of a torch,
the Statue of Liberty now holds
a giant vape pen.
Isn't that cool?
[ Laughter ]
And there's so many exciting
things happening in New York.
In fact, out of the 40,000
airports in the world,
LaGuardia is very close
to becoming one of them.
[ Laughter ]
Finally, you guys, I just want
to say through it all,
New Yorkers are really just
one huge family --
We argue, we fight,
at the end of the day,
we all come together
to make fun of New Jersey.
[ Cheers and applause ]